اعلنت قوات الخفر السواحل اليونانيه مصرع
تسعه 79 من طالبي اللجوء اثر غرق مركبهم
في المياه الاقليميه اليونانيه وقد انقذ
خفره السواحل
104 اشخاص في عمليه وصفها بانها واحده من
اكبر عمليات البحث على الاطلاق في البحر
المتوسط بدورها اشارت المنظمه الدوليه
للهجره التابعه للامم المتحده الى ان
حادثه الغرق هو واحد من اكبر الماسي في
البحر المتوسط مشيره الى وجود ما يصل الى
400 شخص على متن قارب الصيد الغارق في حين
قال شبكه من النشطاء انها تلقت من القارب
بنداء استغاثه تحدث عن وجود ما لا يقل عن
750 شخصا على متنه
انضم الينا من مدينه كلمات اليونانيه
مراسل الجزيره جون
يعني اين وصلت عمليات البحث وماذا عن هذا
التضارب في اعداد الذين كانوا موجودين في
القارب
الاعداد لم تتغير وعدد الناجين رسميا هو
ومن انتشلوهم 79 وعمليات البحث والانقاذ
ما زالت جاريه هناك فرقه يونانيه
وقارب مراقبه لخفر السواحل موجود دان وعدد
من السفن تبحث عن الناجين او حتى الجثث في
منطقه شاسعه هناك عدد من الهليكوبترات
ايضا او المروحيات التي تشارك في البحث
والانقاذ شهاده
الناجين
وردت ولكنها ليست واضحه لان الناس كانوا
مصدومين ولكنهم على رغم ذلك تم اطعامهم
وعالج الجفاف لديهم
وناموا ليلى وبعضهم كان لديهم التهاب
الرئه حيث امتلات رئتاهم بالماء الان تم
اجراء مقابلات معهم
وتم التواصل مع
عائلاتهم وهناك الالاف من المكالمات
الهاتفيه تاتي الى هذا المركز خلفي
والمستشفى المحلي الناس يسالون عن احبتهم
وعائلاتهم
ومن المستحيل ان نعرف ان كان ذووهم من بين
الناجين ام لا الى ان يتم وضع الارقام
النهائيه اذا فهناك عمليه مقابلات ما زالت
جاريه والى ان تنتهي فلن يكون لدينا
معلومات كافيه وافيه عما جرى هل هناك
معلومات عن جنسيات هؤلاء عن اعمارهم على
سبيل المثال ما هي المعلومات المتوفره حتى
الان عن عن عن الذين غرقوا او الذين كانوا
على متن هذا القارب
للاسف هذه المعلومات المتعلقه بالجنسيات
لم تنشر الى الان بعد ولكن قيل لنا رغم
هذا انه تقريبا هناك
سبعين شخص ينامون في مخزن هنا في كلماته
في الميناء كلهم شباب تتراوح عمرهم من 18
الى 30 ربما هم شباب صغار كانوا على متن
القارب ولذلك هم نجوا
والناس الذين في الداخل لم
يحظوا بذات الحظ بانهم نجوا
كما كان الحال لدى هؤلاء شكرا جزيلا لك
مراسل الجزيره من مدينه كلمات اليونانيه